[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de face aux territoires sur
tv5monde en direct avec nos partenaires
de ouest-france donc en direct aussi sur
ouest france.fr sur nicematin.com et sur
franceantilles.fr en léger différé du au
fuseau horaire vous l'imaginez aux
antilles voilà ce sont nos partenaires
co producteur et pour cette émission
nous rajoutons télénantes et nous
saluons dominique luneau le patron de de
télénantes puisque nous recevons la
maire de nantes bonjour johanna rolland
je ne sais pas comment vous appelez
mairesse ou madame la maire puisqu'il ya
les deux choses dit plutôt madame la
maire bon madame là mais alors ce sera
madame la maire vous êtes également
présidente de nantes métropole et vous
êtes la directrice de la campagne
présidentielle d'anne hidalgo tout une
question d'actualité on a appris qu'il
aurait qu il y avait deux cent mille
chômeurs de moins en france on attribue
elisabeth bordels même attribue cet
effet au au quoi qu'il en coûte des
manuels macron ce matin la mise du
travail se fait des confrères est-ce que
c'est quoi qu'il en coûte pour vous est
ce que c'est les effets de la politique
à long terme du gouvernement je crois
que c'est d'abord l'engagement des
entrepreneurs de ce territoire puisqu'on
parle pour une bonne part de l'emploi
dans le domaine du privé en revanche
c'est vrai que dans le soutien au monde
économique il faut le dire le
gouvernement a plutôt été là mais il ya
aussi une mobilisation collective du
pays gouvernement régions métropole sont
venus soutenir les acteurs économiques
ceci dit je le dis au passage autant sur
ce champ le plan de relance a été
présent et je crois on constate en tout
cas plutôt efficace autant il a aussi eu
des points aveugles je le dis parce que
la question sociale pour le coup me
semble totalement absente et elle n'est
pas sans conséquence parce que oui
l'économie redémarre oui dans les
métropoles comme celle que j'ai le
plaisir de diriger le taux de chômage
même s'il est toujours trop importants
restent parmi les plus faibles du pays
autant on a après cette crise des gens
qui se retrouvent encore plus éloignés
de l'emploi et cette question du chômage
de longue durée chômage des jeunes et du
chômage des seniors
les difficultés de reconversion dois je
crois nous interpeller particulièrement
johanna rolland va parler bien sûr
territoire tout au long de cette
émission dans un instant avec françois
des éléphants d'ailleurs qui nous
rejoint questions politiques vous êtes
directrice de la campagne présidentielle
d'anne hidalgo une campagne
présidentielle qui pour l'instant
patine anne hidalgo est autour de 4 %
dans les sondages on se demande avec le
curriculum vitae que vous avez peut-être
90 vous avez une progression politique
phénoménale
qu'avez-vous était faire dans cette
galère
défendre ses valeurs et les convictions
auxquelles on croit vous savez dans le
moment dans lequel elle pays quand on
voit le niveau de désarroi d'une partie
de nos concitoyens quand on voit là mon
fils est en fait en silence quant à
l'envié est là dans l'oeuvre d'anne et
d'une candidate qui prend pas mais
d'abord c'est que le début de la
campagne on est sur la ligne de départ
donc attendons de voir la ligne mais
françois hollande qu'elle cette centrale
des candidats de gauche lilliputienne ça
vous a gêné
sincèrement je préfère ne pas le
commenter et me concentrer sur les
réponses qu'on va apporter aux
françaises et aux français ce qui est
superflu c'est que quand le débat
démocratique est tel qu'il est quand le
débat présidentiel commence de la
manière dont il commence avec je crois
un risque qui est une forme de
confiscation de l'élection
présidentielle aux françaises et aux
français pourquoi je dis ça sur le
terrain les français ils nous parlent
santé nous parle pauvreté il nous parle
emploi sécurité environnement et cette
campagne commence dans un espèce de
bruit et de la fureur donc oui quand on
est une mère de gauche on se bat mais
vous avez conscience qui a une grosse
difficultés sur la personnalité d'alain
d'algos la manière dont lé père c'est
moi ce que je constate surtout c'est
qu'une grande majorité des françaises et
des français ne connaissent pas anne
hidalgo ils ne connaissent pas
l'histoire de cette fille d'immigrés
avec une mère couturière un père
électricien qui vient incarner ce que la
promesse républicaine a permis dans
notre pays une promesse républicaine qui
n'est plus aujourd'hui possible je vais
vous dire une des choses qui m'a donné
envie de m'engager auprès d'elle c'est
justement de faire souffler à nouveau
cette promesse républicaine quand chez
moi à bellevue ou aux dervallières des
jeunes me disent vous savez madame la
maire nous on a joué le jeu de l'école
nous on a pu
des diplômes mais les discriminations
mais la difficulté c'est qu'on a du mal
aujourd'hui à se sentir dans la
république bien oui ça vaut le coup de
se battre
vous avez une idée de ce qu'ils se sont
dit ou ce qu'ils vont se dire françois
hollande et anne hidalgo j'ai vu que il
la recevait d'écouté il est l'ancien
président de la république de gauche
c'est naturel que des échanges existent
et puis c'est aussi l'ensemble de cette
génération qui aujourd'hui soutient sa
démarche bernard cazeneuve était à lille
il a eu des mots très forts pour
soutenir la femme d'état quel est il a
eu des mots qui se dit dans cette
conversation hollande hidalgo si bien
sûr des échanges sur la situation du
pays des échanges sur la responsabilité
la gauche peut vous savez anne hidalgo
c'est une femme fidèle mais libre donc
elle trace son chemin son sillon à elle
voit là et bien c'est johanna rolland
que la maire de nantes et président de
nantes métropole qui est notre invité
politique aujourd'hui on passe aux
territoires françois-xavier l'offrant le
rédacteur en chef de ouest france nous
rejoint sur ce plateau
bonjour françois xavier le franc vous
êtes le rédacteur en chef du plus grand
quotidien français le premier quotidien
de langue francophone au monde
exactement bonjour là bonjour on démarre
avec des questions liées au
développement au développement vous êtes
à la tête de l'une des grandes
agglomérations françaises vous présidez
d'ailleurs france urbaine c'est c'est
l'association des grandes villes
françaises et vous avez aussi présidé
européennes c'était lors du lors du
précédent mandat alors ces villes elle
se développe considérablement c'est le
cas de nantes et d'autres villes avec
des problématiques parfois lourds dont
on va parler pendant cette émission de
mobilité de sécurité d'emploi de
transport est-ce qu'on maîtrise encore
la ville aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas condamné finalement à essayer
de de modeler ce modèle urbain qui
pousse qui pousse de façon très forte de
façon très spectaculaire sur les
territoires deux choses je crois que ce
modèle urbain il doit évoluer et
continuer à évoluer en revanche je le
dis de manière très claire je pense
qu'il faut aussi arrêter le métro paul
bachy n'y a pour moi c'est quelque chose
de très important parce que quand on
entend cette petite musique assez
négative en permanence et pas très
constructive on oublie que les grandes
métropoles de ce pays c'est aujourd'hui
80 % de l'emploi ce sont des chu ce sont
des centres d'innovation ce sont des
capitales culturelles s'est pas d'abord
des constructions administrative c'est
d'abord des hommes et des femmes qui
habitent dans une commune travaille dans
l'hôte dont les enfants vont faire des
études à l'iut de la commune d'à côté et
puis surtout arrêtons de fragmenter on
assure jouer l'opposition entre les
villes et les campagnes est ce qu'il ya
des questions de désertification des
services publics par exemple dans le
rural bien sûr mais il ya aussi des
capacités d'innovation formidable dans
le rural oui donc moi je crois que nos
villes doivent évoluer il ya eu deux
modèles de métropole je crois que le
moment est venu d'inventer le troisième
premier modèle de métropole c'est celle
qui parfois ont asséché les territoires
autour d'elle donc c'est les
conséquences que ça peut produire
ensuite il ya eu les métropoles qui ont
irrigué les territoires environnement si
j'étais un peu taquine girex et la
théorie du ruissellement versus les
métropoles moi je crois qu'on doit
inventer le troisième modèle est le
troisième modèle c'est l'interaction la
complémentarité entre les territoires
urbains et les territoires périurbains
et ruraux la semaine dernière j'étais à
guérande avec le président du conseil
départemental de chez moi l'ensemble des
présidents intercommunaux pour dire sur
les sujets mobilité sur les sujets
d'alimentation parce que la pollution
elle a pas de frontières administratives
demain on travaille ensemble alors sur
les territoires périurbains ce qu'on
appelait autrefois les zones dortoirs
c'est pas très beau mais il faut créer
du lien social et là les métropoles ont
eu un rôle à jouer mais dans les
territoires ruraux c'est vrai qu'il ya
une inquiétude souvent c'est le cas
c'est le cas dans l'ouest mais c'est le
cas dans d'autres régions françaises et
territoires ruraux qui souffrent aussi
d'un certain nombre de problématiques
qui voient parfois l'état se désengage
et et qui voit ses métropoles grandir
comment expliquer à ces territoires et
comment est-ce que les métropoles
peuvent apporter de la dynamique à ces
territoires et comment créer ce lien
indispensable entre territoires c'est
d'ailleurs l'objet de deux je crois de
l'association fonction ben ainslie tout
à fait de france urbaine défend cette
idée qui m'est chère de l'alliance des
territoires en dix ans on a destin
commun chacun n'est pas dans sa bulle je
prendre un exemple très concret dans nos
grandes villes on veut augmenter la part
du bio dans les cantines si on veut le
faire on a un enjeu de création de
filières en amont et en aval et alors on
crée de la valeur ajoutée parce que nos
villes elles sont pas des îles elle
travaille en résonance vous prenez le
sujet des mobilités on résoudra pas la
congestion dans nos grandes villes sans
penser le grand territoire et c'est
évident qu'on n'a pas le même rapport à
la voiture individuelle quand on habite
dans l'hyper centre d'une grande
métropole comme la mienne ou quand on
habite à 40 ou 50 km mais en revanche il
ya aussi des points communs prenons le
sujet de la santé qui fait l'actualité
là à raison depuis quelques jours la
désertification médicale la difficulté
d'accès aux soins avec lé vré à l'europe
a nantes au courant par de la faire
rentrer people elle est vrai aussi bien
dans le coeur des quartiers populaires
d'une grande ville comme la mienne que
dans que dans les territoires ruraux la
problématique est la même donc vraiment
je crois qu'il faut cesser d'opposer
chercher des réponses qui peuvent
paraître des réponses d'une réalisation
des territoires donc la campagne
présidentielle démarre ce sera l'un des
thèmes de campagne est ce qu'on a besoin
d'une nouvelle grandbois d'organisation
des territoires de décentralisation très
certainement qu'est ce que vous allez
porter comme idée pour une meilleure
organisation des territoires en france
je pense qu'on a terriblement besoin
d'une nouvelle étape de la
décentralisation
on reste dans un pays très jacobin dans
un pays très décentralisé ateurs qui
plus est l'exercice pouvoir de ce
quinquennat a quand même été très
jacobin très jupitérien on a besoin de
souffle d'air moi je suis pour un état
fort juste pour un état stratège sur
leur régaliens -justice sécurité
éducation de l'état doit être fort mais
laisser faire aux territoires ce qu'ils
savent faire et puis c'est un changement
de modèle parce que le sujet c'est est
ce que les collectivités locales elles
sont des simples courroies de
transmission d'un pouvoir national où
est-ce qu'on leur laisse 7 part
d'imagination d'expérimentation la crise
l'a montré sans collectivités y aurait
pas une masse qu il y aurait pas eu de
test n'y aurait pas eu de centres de
vaccination la puissance logistique de
l'êta c'est pour une part effondré il
faut avoir la lucidité de ce diagnostic
si on veut trouver les bonnes réponses
pour les français parce que c'est ça le
seul sujet qui compte à la fin c'est
johanna rolland maire de nantes
présidente de la métropole de nantes qui
est notre invité politique ce matin en
face au territoire ouest france est
allée rencontrer sébastien mallet qui a
un restaurant qui se mêlent tapas et 20
à nantes chez vous et il a une question
à vous poser il parle de la sécurité
dans son quartier depuis 5 6 ans
sentiment d'insécurité qui monte je me
suis fait plusieurs fois agressé je suis
obligé de raccompagner
[Musique]
mon staff mon personnel le soir tard en
fin de service pour éviter entre
guillemets les agressions répétées et
multiples et eu des efforts de fait
qu'on reconnaît concerne entre email
l'augmentation policiers municipaux
samedi dernier 19 heures quelqu'un
m'attende et pour planter avec un stylo
il est 19 heures on parle même pas de
23h que pensez-vous faire et à quand une
la police municipale h 24 sur nantes 5e
métropoles françaises cph a dit lambert
1 qu'il a rencontré de ouest france la
trouver bah très sensible à ces
questions il
a raison d'y être sensible moi c'est un
sujet de préoccupation et bataille
permanente j'ai posé une règle pour
trouver des réponses parce que sur ces
sujets la seule chose qui compte c'est
l'efficacité
cette règle c'était l'idée du un tourin
quand la ville met un on est fort en
plus l'état doit mettre un j'ai signé
avec le ministre de l'intérieur monsieur
darmana un contrat de sécurité dans
lequel la ville s'engage à recruter 70
policiers municipaux en plus mais où
l'état qui doit aussi prendre sa part
parce que si les villes avance et que
l'état recule évidemment ça va pas
résoudre le problème des gens donc là
j'ai obtenu enfin que l'état s'engage
sur 70 policiers nationaux
supplémentaires c'est une bataille cette
bataille il faut l'amener avec la plus
grande fermeté ce que nous faisons à
nantes mais c'est ce qui se passe dans
l'ensemble des grandes villes du pays et
ça il faut avoir cette conscience là
parce que effectivement le commerçant
qui parle comme partout dans notre pays
il se retrouve en première ligne et vous
avez deux types de réactions parmi les
maires que vous évoquiez tout à l'heure
il ya ceux qui disent c'est le chant du
régalien c'est le chant d'état on doit
pas s'en occuper moi je fais partie de
ceux qui disent principe de réalité je
ne peux plus accepter que ce sujet
montrent autant donc on y va on met les
moyens on met le paquet avec l'ensemble
de la chaîne évidemment votre éducation
prévention mais quand c'est nécessaire
le sanctions et ferme entre autant de
policiers municipaux que l'état apporte
deux policiers de le deux policiers
nationaux mais au delà de policiers en
plus qu'est ce qu'on peut faire c'est
pas c'est pas faire de la métropole
machine que deux notez que ce phénomène
dans les villes il est grandissant il
est spectaculaire et on a un peu
l'impression qu' on ne sait pas comment
traiter ça la question des trafics de
drogue qui prend quand même une ampleur
absolument dingue dans nos villes
françaises nous rappelle bordeaux
marseille lyon à lens ont annoncé leur
entière il ya le court terme on met des
policiers c'est important d'ailleurs se
demander qu'est ce qu'on peut faire de
plus qu'est ce qu'une métropole peut
faire de plus au moins trois choses
d'abord on mène collectivement la
bataille de l'espace public pour moi
c'est indispensable la bataille de
l'espace public c'est que à chaque
endroit où il y a lieu de deal où il y a
trafic il doit y avoir d'intervention il
ya le court terme il ya une intervention
il se passe quelque chose il ya long
terme ça c'est tout le travail de la
police judiciaire parce que si on
démantèle pas les trafics au fond on ne
règle pas le sujet ensuite il ya tout le
volet de la prévention de la lutte
contre la récidive parce que moi je
m'oppose à cette idée d'une forme
d'assignations de parcours parmi celles
et ceux qui commettent des actes de
délinquance va bien falloir proposer ces
parcours de réinsertion et de ce point
de vue les villes peuvent aussi
contribuer quand on accueille celle des
ceux qui sont en travaux d'intérêts
généraux ou quand on monte comme on va
le faire a nantes un conseil pour les
familles pour jouer aussi le rappel à la
règle le rappel à la vie collective et
puis enfin il ya la question de la
justice et ce maillon il est
indispensable il est indispensable parce
que tous les acteurs de terrain voulions
si ce maillon n'est pas au rendez vous
quand quelqu'un est jugé par exemple 15
mois après l'acte qu'il a commis quelle
capacité à remettre du civisme en
campagne y aura beaucoup de surenchère
sur la sécurité c'est un grand c'est un
grand classique la gauche a toujours
semblé un peu mal à l'aise avec ça jeudi
semblait parce qu'il ya des actions qui
sont faites dans les villes quel discour
quelle politique allez vous porter avec
anne hidalgo sur la question de la
sécurité sur lesquelles beaucoup vous
attendent qu'elle quel discours fort
allez vous portez là dessus moi je fais
partie de ces élus de gauche qui assume
totalement les sujets de sécurité pour
une raison simple ça fait partie de la
bataille pour l'égalité donc quand on
est un homme ou une femme de gauche on
se bat pour l'égalité et la sécurité en
fait partie
je peux vous dire que quand michaël
delafosse travail à montpellier où
mathieu klein travail à nancy nous
faisons partie de cette génération
d'élus qui disent il ya là un sujet va
pas faire la politique de l'autruche
c'est difficile c'est difficile et
méfions nous des instrumentalisations et
vous avez raison la campagne
présidentielle de ce point de vue peut
aussi ouvrir la porte à toutes les
surenchères qui ne règle jamais les
questions des français
chaunu qui est dessinateur bien connue
de ouest-france collaborateurs très
régulier de votre journal
françois-xavier le franc à une question
sous forme de dessin c'est la tradition
de cette émission a posé à johanna
rolland on regarde on écoute
madame la présidente
non je ne vais pas vous parler du
dernier livre de françois hollande mais
plutôt des deux roues voici ma question
pourquoi la gauche est plus engagé pour
affronter le réchauffement climatique
que pour affronter les incivilités qui
ruine la qualité de vie de nos
agglomérations
monsieur j'ai envie de vous inviter dans
nos villes vous verrez vraiment content
les vos travaux dans la mienne mais dans
celle de nathalie appéré à rennes où
nicolas mayer rossignol harwood de cette
équipe de france 1 des mers avec
lesquels je travaille dans nos villes on
choisit pas entre la lutte contre les
incivilités et prendre nos
responsabilités sur le réchauffement
climatique je crois que des élus moderne
j'allais dire de notre génération il
affronte les deux sont pas forcément
toutes les réponses mais en tout cas ils
posent un certain nombre d'options très
clair françois que j'avais le frange
vous tient sur ce plateau vous êtes
l'homme qui a déclaré aux médias la
semaine dernière que ouest france ne
publierait plus de sondages je vais
poser la question à jouer un rôle en est
ce qu'elle trouve que c'est une bonne ou
mauvaise idée la décision était prise
de manière unanime il à ouest france oui
tout à fait ce n'est pas les instituts
de sondage que nous mettons en cause ils
font leur boulot sérieusement mais c'est
la façon dont les médias utilisent les
sondages pour assommer les citoyens avec
des
résultats qui sont qui ne sont même pas
vérifié qu'ils sont assénées comme ça
jour après jour semaine après semaine
alors qu'il ya tant de sujets importants
à discuter donc nous avons fait le choix
de ne pas parler des intentions de vote
mais de parler des sujets qui
préoccupent les citoyens et nous nous y
tiendrons strictement parce que nous
pensons que le il ya là une dérive qui
est inquiétante pour la démocratie
réponse de la directrice de campagne
d'hamid algo qu'est ce que vous pensez
de cette initiative de ouest france je
relayais il est courageuse et salutaire
pour une raison je suis frappé de voir
que tous les jours on me dit
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce qu'a dit
adel qui attend dans les sondages mais
qu'est ce que vous pensez de tels
sondages je crois que ça n'amène aucune
réponse aux françaises et aux français
la noblesse du débat démocratique c'est
de dire quel est l'état de la société
quelle vision qu'on propose et quel
chemin pour y parvenir il ya des
utilisations sérieuse et sondages
d'autres pas sérieuse on voit pas être
manichéen sur ce sujet mais quand même
on est dans un moment démocratique assez
grave je veux le dire moi je suis
inquiète de la tournure que prend le
début de la campagne on l'avait dit tout
à l'heure et ce bruit et cette fureur
dont je trouve que c'est un acte de
responsabilité pour contribuer à un
débat démocratique de qualité que la
voix du nord d'ailleurs consacre sa une
ce matin également à cette interrogation
faut-il publier systématiquement les
sondages françois xavier le franc la une
de ouest france alors la lune de ouest
france nous évoquons la réouverture des
lieux culturels c'est encore un peu
timide et on a envie que ça s'accélère
et puis surtout nous parlons aussi de la
de la campagne oui il ya beaucoup trop
de sondage et pas assez de programme
donc on attend avec impatience les
programmes et on veut débattre de ces
programmes merci françois xavier le
franc rédacteur en chef de ouest france
le plus grand quotidien de langue
française au monde merci denis carot
dans un instant sur ce plateau
bonjour denis carot deuxième partenaire
de cette émission directeur des
rédactions du groupe nice matin dans un
instant ce sera à vous interroger notre
invité politique ce matin donc johanna
rolland maire de nantes met tout de
suite si les boutiques et directeur de
rédaction qui même groupe que vous
france antilles à une question à poser à
jaune à roland il s'agit de l'adaptation
des règles d'urgence sanitaire pour les
antilles précisément l'écoutent bonjour
journée à roland dans vos territoires la
situation sociale est particulièrement
tendue notamment à cause de la crise
sanitaire mais également face au refus
de l'obligation vaccinale chez les
soignants que ce soit en martinique en
guadeloupe en guyane le gouvernement il
répond en envoyant une médiation afin de
tenter de renouer un dialogue entre les
parties il propose également un
amendement qui permettrait de prolonger
l'état d'urgence sanitaire jusqu'au 31
décembre
seriez-vous favorable comme un certain
nombre de représentants syndicaux à une
adaptation de la loi pour les
territoires d'outre-mer et
singulièrement pour les antilles
spécificités d'une certaine manière en
matière de politique sanitaire je crois
que à l'évidence il y a sur les
territoires que vous évoquez une
situation particulière en termes
d'activité en termes de chiffres de
vaccination et une absence de leurs
merdes et bien sûr c'est ce à quoi je
fais référence donc oui il me semble
qu'il faut trouver des solutions pour
adapter les réponses notre république
elle est une et indivisible
ça c'est très important mais elle n'est
pas uniforme à titre personnel je lui
dis moi je suis plutôt pour la
vaccination obligatoire parce que je
pense que ça aurait le mérite de
clarifier mais je vais le concerto bira
je fais le constat que sur les
territoires que vous évoquez il y a une
difficulté si une part plus grande
adaptation de différenciation permet
d'avancer eh bien je crois qu'il faut
tenter une approche pragmatique la prof
de christiane taubira lacunes
ne vous a pas convenu mais écoutez je
commande pas le propos de x ou y je
réponds à la question de monsieur je
vous le dis moi je suis plutôt favorable
à la vaccination obligatoire dans le
pays là il y a une problématique
particulière il faut l'entendre faut
partir de la réalité de ces territoires
l'étape pas décidé ça tout seul allons
d'abord cherché la voix de ceux qui sont
sur le terrain des élus qui sont sur le
terrain des organisations syndicales qui
sont sur le terrain pour trouver des
réponses pour trouver des remèdes parce
que la situation paraît quand même très
préoccupante denis carot avec quelle
écologie pour les villas complètement
bonjour je relance on voit que toutes
les métropoles sont aujourd'hui engagés
fortement dans la transition écologique
avec des recettes et des rythmes
différents vous défendez de votre côté
avant tout une écologie sociale alors à
quoi ça ressemble une écologie sociale
et ça se traduit concrètement de quelle
manière pour les habitants de nantes
politiquement une écologie sociale c'est
l'économie ou l'écologie par donc on met
au service de la lutte contre les
inégalités
ça c'est l'idée de fond c'est une
écologie qui n'est pas une écologique
que pour les plus aisés ou pour les
bobos pour le dire de manière encore
plus direct mais une écologie pour tout
le monde y compris pour les plus
modestes et les plus fragiles comment ça
se traduit concrètement deux exemples ah
non que nous avons mis en place la
gratuité des transports en commun le
week-end parce que c'est bon pour le
climat bon pour pouvoir d'achat et vous
savez comment ce sujet en ce moment
préoccupe les habitants lui que ça vient
soutenir nos commerçants du centre-ville
qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure mais c'est
aussi les logements sociaux qui sont
chauffés aux énergies renouvelables
parce que là aussi c'est bon pour le
climat et puis bon pour le porte-monnaie
des locataires donc c'est à chaque fois
se dire que on frappe à la transition
écologique sans les classes moyennes et
les plus modestes et que pour ça on
trouve des réponses concrètes pour
permettre la conjugaison des deux alors
vous l'avez dit vous avez mis en place
le les transports publics gratuits le
week-end comme dans d'autres dans
d'autres grandes villes vous encourager
fortement la pratique
du vélo est ce à dire que la voiture les
scooters thermiques n'ont plus leur
place à nantes non on s'est fixé des
objectifs très clairs on les a même
chiffré aujourd'hui on dit que ce qu'on
appelle la part modale c'est à peu près
40 3% et on voudrait qu'en 2030 on soit
à 27% vous voyez la trajectoire elle est
claire et assumée c'est une réduction
nette ne s'est pas une disparition c'est
pas une disparition parce que certains
d'entre nous en fonction de leur métier
de leurs rythmes auront besoin en
revanche c'est la voiture autrement
c'est le développement du covoiturage
pour ça il faut des voies dédiées c'est
le fait de pouvoir raisonner pas que
intra métropole la vraie question de
demain c'est à quel endroit se fait la
jonction entre la voiture et les
transports en commun c'est le
développement du vélo et de la marche à
pied n'oublions pas la marche à pied ou
c'est dans nos grandes villes beaucoup
de déplacements sont des déplacements de
500 m donc quand on a une sensibilité au
sujet de santé on sait aussi que cette
question est majeur donc on assume des
choix forts des lignes de transport en
commun structurants qu une réflexion sur
les usages le développement du vélo et
la claire conscience je le disais tout à
l'heure on n'a pas le même rapport à la
voiture selon son métier selon la
période de l'année selon qu'on habite
dans l'hyper centre de nantes ou à noël
ou à guérande pour prendre des exemples
de mon territoire pour le maintien du
permis à points bien sûr je vraiment
vous faites la référence à la
proposition d'eric zemmour sur ce sujet
on savait déjà que monsieur zemmour
était un danger pour la cohésion de
notre pays qu'il était un danger pour la
démocratie maintenant c'est qu'il est
aussi un danger pour la sécurité des
français quand même hein je le dis je
vais au bout entre le moment où permis à
points était mise en oeuvre et
aujourd'hui on a quasiment divisé par
deux le nombre de morts dans notre pays
franchement alors justement dylan
meiffret de nice matin votre groupe
denis carot a rencontré frédéric ozon
qui est le président de l'automobile
club de nice il a des propositions liées
justement aux automobilistes et à la
réglementation affaire est une question
à vous poser
madame roland vous restaurer les 30 km
heure en ville pour apaiser la
circulation que pensez-vous des annonces
de monsieur zemmour de ce week-end qui
prône la fin du permis à points la fin
les quatre vainqueurs espoirs sur route
et la fin des limitations mutation
autoroute c'est plus large la question
encore là je pense que c'est une
position irresponsable je pèse mes mots
et je le redis quand le permis à points
a été instaurée il y avait à peu près de
9000 morts on est passé à
3500 comment on peut prétendre à la plus
grande fonction du pays et avoir une
position aussi populiste qui met en
danger la sécurité des français je crois
qu'il faut le dire avec une grande force
et une grande fermeté vous l'avez dit à
quelqu'un qui est férus d'automobile qui
est lui-même pilote denis carot
on a vu le débat autour de l'inflation
et du coût de l'énergie et des
carburants jean castex a annoncé la
semaine dernière la mise en place de
cette prime inflation de 100 euros est
ce que c'était la bonne idée c'est trop
tard est insuffisant prenons une
situation réelle une mère de famille qui
élève seule ses trois enfants qui gagne
de 1050 euros par mois elle n'est pas
concernée par cette aide et pourtant je
peux vous garantir que le 21 du mois il
commence même le 15 en ce moment dans ce
type de famille anne hidalgo sur ce
sujet a fait une proposition très clair
en disant à situation exceptionnelle
réponse exceptionnelle baisse immédiate
de la tave et de la tva pour le passé en
produits de première nécessité on sait
qu'on va aller vers la sortie des
véhicules thermiques donc on doit aussi
accompagner les ménages vers le
changement de véhicule nous on veut que
pour une fois les derniers soient les
premiers si je dis manière rapide
autrement dit que les classes moyennes
les ouvriers les salariés puissent aller
vers un changement de véhicule et de
véhicules électriques mais en attendant
la l'urgence c'est la colère qui gronde
sur le pouvoir d'achat c'est l'injustice
de la vie quotidienne sur ce sujet donc
vraiment je crois que cette mesure elle
est à côté il n'est pas trop tard pour
rejoindre cette proposition qui ferait
sens dans la vie de nos concitoyens
alors justement la consommation
d'électricité va augmenter de 35% dans
les 30 dans les 30 ans qui viennent dans
le rapport
présenté lundi rte évoque le
développement des énergies renouvelables
mais estime que le nucléaire reste
nécessaire et qu'il est pertinent de
construire de nouveaux réacteurs on ne
peut pas faire autrement en réalité
quand on lit l'intégralité du rapport
rta pardon il ya 6 avril deux il ya six
scénarios donc en fait ce que dit rt
assez hauts responsables politiques de
faire leur choix et d'assumer le cap
qu'ils veulent prendre nous le cap que
nous défendons il est clair on doit
augmenter le plus possible le
renouvelable et la part du nucléaire
restantes doit s'adapter aux
renouvelables qu'on aura fait monter est
ce qu'il faut pour situer la même
science donne pas de nouveau réel c'est
pas du tout la même chose il faut
d'abord dire où on veut emmener le pays
et nous nous considérons que l'équipe
actuelle n'est pas assez ambitieuse sur
le champ du renouvelable est ce qu'on
peut se passer du nucléaire demain matin
non c'est très clair qu'il faut
construire de nouvelles centrales je
pense que ça mérite un débat je pense
que ça mérite de passer cela au
parlement c'est une question d'exercice
du pouvoir mais je le redis je pense que
l'ambition sur l'énergie renouvelable
est très faible la note c'est d'aller
beaucoup plus loin sur ce sujet les
fermetures de services se multiplient
dans les hôpitaux anne hidalgo étaient à
saint vallier dans la drôme hier 20 %
des lits sont actuellement fermés et on
voit que la situation se dégrade de jour
en jour depuis la crise sanitaire
quelles solutions peut-on imaginer pour
favoriser le recrutement et la formation
des soignants ce sujet est extrêmement
préoccupant vraiment d'abord parce que
il préexistait à la crise sanitaire on
avait des signaux d'alerté les
difficultés de remplacements le taux
d'absentéisme
les équipes qui disait la fatigue ils
ont tenu le pays de manière admirable
pendant la crise sanitaire vraiment
enfin moi j'ai vu sur le terrain des
médecins des infirmières des aides
soignantes qui ont tout donné c'est
d'abord grâce à eux si le pays a tenu
ensuite il ya eu cette annonce du ségur
de la santé qui a permis quelques
avancées mais qui a aussi laissé
certains pans de côté 1 dans le champ du
médico-social un certain nombre de
professionnels qui se sont démenés
parfois au delà de leurs fortes ne sont
pas il faut que les revenus plus cher
les infirmières je pense d'abord qu'il
faut ouvrir le numerus clausus ce
qu'anne hidalgo a dit hier lors de son
déplacement l'ouvrir le tu as aimé saint
vallier il faut regarder mais peut-être
même le supprimer il faut regarder les
conditions de travail on a un sujet très
précis demandé aux infirmières qui sont
en cycle de nuit combien ils gagnent en
plus quand elles font des heures de nuit
quand c'est à quel point c'est
destructeur des mobilisateurs pour leur
vie de famille beaucoup de nouvelles si
cette ville bien sûr on a aussi des
phénomènes de génération les médecins
actuels les infirmières actuelle les
aides soignants actuels ne sont pas
prêts forcément à faire ce que leurs
aînés ont fait on a là un sujet de
société absolument immense il faut
revenir sur la suppression des 5700 lee
évidemment dans les hôpitaux et je le
dis ce mouvement et ne date pas d'hier
il est enclenchée depuis trop longtemps
il faut vraiment qu'on garde la santé
autrement ensuite il ya des questions
d'organisation parlera décentralisation
tout à l'heure j'ai notamment la
collègue en drs là moi je pense que les
collectivités ont leur mot à dire en
matière de santé la crise a montré un
qu'il y avait là un enjeu de compétences
un enjeu d'organisation du parcours la
société vieillit et on va avoir des
passages à l'hôpital plus court ce qu'on
appelle la montée de l'ambulatoire donc
si on passe puis on pense pas l'amont et
l'aval de l'hospitalisation et ça ça se
passe avec la médecine deux villes ça se
passe avec les seconds si on raisonne
très en silo il ya urgence à regarder ça
de manière beaucoup plus globale avec
deux infirmières ou sauvé qui sont payés
trois fois mieux en allemagne qu'en
france
l'enjeu de la reconnaissance salariale
de ses métiers comme de nombreux métiers
dans notre pays de ceux qui sont en
première ligne et je prends aujourd'hui
un sujet absolument majeur denis carot
la une de nice matin la une de
nice-matin le fléau du démarchage
téléphonique
de plus en plus de gens se sentent
harcelés
les appels sont incessants et le système
qui a été mis en place qui s'appelle
blocs telle ne marche pas donc c'est une
vraie question est qui
pose de nombreux problèmes aux azuréens
que nous avons rencontrés avec des
possibilités d'amélioration pas avec
pour le moment assez peu de possibilités
d'amélioration et c'est bien le problème
merci denis carot directeur des
rédactions de nice-matin dans un instant
les questions internationales avec
johanna rolland la maire de nantes qui
est notre invité politique
voilà il pour les traiter et bien
d'émettre korkmaz de tv5monde dans un
bourg des maîtres merci d'être avec nous
on démarre avec amazon absolument de ma
zone demain le collectif stop amazon 44
va célébrer sa victoire contre le géant
du e-commerce qui devait implanter un
entrepôt 285000 185 mille mètres carrés
au sud de nantes est ce que les
entreprises étrangères ont encore une
place bien sûr mais la question c'est
quelle entreprise étrangère et pour
faire quoi moi j'avais clairement dit
que je pensais que ce modèle d'amazon ne
correspondait pas au modèle économique
de notre territoire vous savez on est
une des métropoles les plus dynamiques
du pays une région particulièrement
active des entrepreneurs qui
investissent qui prennent les risques tu
peux vous garantir que nos entrepreneurs
locaux ne voyait pas d'un très bon oeil
l'arrivée du géant amazon parce que
quand un collectif d'artisans et de
commerçants locale met en place une
plateforme numérique vous voyez bien la
concurrence totalement déloyale d'un
grand groupe qui n'est pas forcément
imposé sur la fiscalité au niveau où il
devrait l'être donc le sujet c'est
quelle économie quel modèle économique
qu'elle emploie oui pour travailler avec
les entrepreneurs non pour faire tous
sont égaux analyse à des gens qui ne
respectent pas les règles du jeu d'une
vie collective votre prise de conscience
elle est récente et les liés à la
pandémie parce que le permis de
construire avait été délivré tout de
même en mars 2020 ne laisse que c'est
par ce revirement quand même un très
mauvais signe je ne sais pas pourquoi
vous parler de deux revirements
un permis de faire avait été délivré par
sur quelle commune
sur une commune dit plusieurs fois les
communes ont les meilleurs de la commune
qui reste un très mauvais signe johanna
rolland qu'on envoie aux entreprises
étrangères dont on dit qu président
macron dit tout le temps qu'il faut que
la france soit attractive et large on
stoppe amazon est la plus grande
entreprise du monde je crois pas parce
que je reprends l'exemple de ma région
on accueille tous les mois des nouvelles
entreprises y compris les entreprises
internationales bien sûr on en est très
fier dans des secteurs qu'on a choisi à
nantes on a un certain nombre de
filières d'excellence santé du futur
industries du futur alimentation du
futur numérique les industries
culturelles et créatives sur ces
secteurs là bien sûr qu'on a besoin donc
c'était un besoin l'entreprise lola il
ya un modèle avec lesquels on est en
désaccord ce qu'il faille charte est ce
qu'il faut une charte pour les
entreprises étrangères crois qu'il faut
bien plus qu'une charte il faut des
règles du jeu européenne notamment sur
les enjeux puisque qualité alors en
parlant de l'europe et aussi à la versio
la van der leyen la présente de la
commission européenne a mis en avant le
travail des villes et des collectivités
locales pendant la crise
et notamment dans la mise en oeuvre des
plans de relance elles pensent que ces
structures sont importantes sont des
relais importants est ce que pour vous
il manque un échelon entre les villes et
l'union européenne oui à l'évidence
c'est un sujet absolument majeur parce
que on est en train de lancer des plans
de relance partout je rappelle que
l'europe en réalité finances 40% du plan
de relance français et c'est important
parce que dans un moment soyez 1,10
milliard d'euros bien sûr devoir revoir
leur part les pays européens à quoi ça
sert l'enduro bien s'ils avaient pas
l'europe on n'aurait pas ce niveau de
plans de relance donc d'abord je pense
qu'il faut le saluer en revanche c'est
vrai que dans un pays comme le nôtre par
exemple 70% de l'investissement public
passe par les collectivités locales il
ya quand même quelque chose d'assez
aberrant à ce que aujourd'hui les
collectivités locales soit pour une part
les oubliés du plan de relance pour des
questions d'efficacité
j'ai présidé pendant deux ans le réseau
eurocities qui regroupe les 130 grandes
de l'europe et c'est vrai qu'un
changement de culture instituée dans les
sphères européennes comment dès le début
en anticipation nos villes nos régions
sont associés à l'élaboration des
politiques publiques européennes comme
on dit aujourd'hui pour que ce soit le
plus efficace possible à partir de
sujets contemporains on se bat par
exemple avec plusieurs de mes homologues
pour que l'europe se penche sur la
question vous savez des livreurs dans
nos villes et notamment des livreurs à
vélo quelles conditions de travail
quelle rémunération
voilà un sujet de fond de sens dont
l'europe peut se saisir dans ce dialogue
avec les vidéos la question des livreurs
il ya eu 1 vous avez eu maille à partir
avec les livreurs en centre ville vous
leur avait interdit l'accès en scooter
thermique est ce que vous parlais tout à
l'heure de cette écologie qui devait
être une écologie sociale et qu'ils ne
devaient pas qu'ils ne devaient pas
uniquement profiter aux bobos des de
l'hyper centre est-ce qu'il n'y avait
pas un autre moyen de les accompagner
plutôt que de leur interdire de
travailler avec un scooter thermique
nous les accompagnons nous les
accompagnons puisque à nantes nous
soutenons un certain nombre de
plateformes qui travaille sur les
conditions de travail sérieuse de ces
personnes moi je crois qu'il faut être
clair donc nous on veut la transition
écologique et on veut la sécurité et la
tranquillité pour les habitants donc oui
j'assume totalement cette interdiction
scooter thermique le vrai sujet c'est le
niveau d'exploitation des hommes et des
femmes qui font ce métier ce que vous
avez vu leur journée ce que vous avez vu
combien ils sont rémunérés la
responsabilité elle est effectivement
que ces groupes puisse à un moment donné
prendre la mesure qu'en france en 2021
on n'exploite pas pardon de le dire de
cette manière des hommes et des femmes
et si notre démarche et les homologues
européens qui s'y sont joints permet de
faire bouger les lignes et bien nos
territoires ont été une nouvelle fête
plus futiles le passé esclavagiste de
nantes oui alors justement
nantes et a été un grand port négrier le
plus grand de france longtemps cette
histoire a été occultée aujourd'hui elle
est mise en avant est ce qu'aujourd'hui
pour nom pour la ville de nantes cette
question et pacifiées oui je crois que
vraiment il faut saluer nos
prédécesseurs quand je dis nos
prédécesseurs je pense à jean marc
ayrault qui a pris l'initiative sur ce
sujet mais qu'il a fait avec les acteurs
associatifs de nantes en disant on va
regarder se passait bien en face sans
esprit de repentance avec une lucidité
assumé donc on a eu plusieurs étapes 1
dans l'histoire nantaise grande
exposition qui avait recueilli plus de
quatre cent mille visiteurs au château
des ducs de bretagne on a fait le choix
d'installer un mémorial pour lutter
contre l'abolition de l'esclavagé pour
donner à voir de la manière dont ça
avait imprégné nos sociétés et puis on
vient d'avoir la loue verture d'une
grande exposition au château à nouveau
je crois que ces sujets méritent
de regarder les choses avec une analyse
poser si on veut éviter là aussi les
instrumentalisations diverses et vers le
nord où je salue l'action de mon
prédécesseur sur ce sujet et nantes
continue de poser des actes justement
parlant le rôle de jean marc ayrault
dans la campagne daddy delgo il va être
important par de vue bernard cazeneuve
aux premières loges à lise à lille le
cas dernier mais est-ce que c'est pas
l'habitude de parler pour jean marc
ayrault mais ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que c'est un homme de valeur un
homme de conviction et puis que il fait
aussi partie de ce je le dis c'est pas
si fréquent qu'ils ont aussi su préparer
la transition et qui ne sont pas dans
une logique après moi il ne se passe
rien et qui est plutôt cette nouvelle
génération dont je fais partie à prendre
ses responsabilités donc voulu inviterez
et je ne doute pas qu'il vous dira bien
sûr qu'on va l'inviter ce qu'ils pensent
de ces sujets il a aujourd'hui pris
beaucoup de recul sur la vie politique
en revanche il préside cette fondation
nationale de l'expulsion vous avez
souhaité couper ce cordon ombilical avec
jean marc ayrault à un an l'association
pas dit votre meilleure danse très vite
les choses
tout fait de cette manière là on a une
amitié
vous lui coupez non c'est vie c'est bien
méconnaître la relation que j'ai avec
jean marc ayrault en revanche c'est pour
ça que je le disais parce que c'est très
rare en politique je crois qu'il savait
que pour que les choses fonctionnent
bien il fallait que chacun joue son rôle
et il a fait le choix de passer à une
autre étape de sa vie ce qui n'empêche
pas de continuer à être un observateur
avisé qu'est-ce que vous ferai après la
direction de campagne de nidal go mais
écoutez je continuerai à m'occuper des
nantais c'est ma passion de chaque jour
je parlais en politique bien sûr sociaux
mais c'est faire de la politique est
maire d'une grande ville et en politique
nationale vous avez des ambitions mais
je continuerai à défendre mes valeurs et
mes convictions quand on voit la
situation du pays on a besoin d'une voie
de gauche ssq avec tous mes collègues de
cette équipe de france des mères nous
faisons avec beaucoup d'enthousiasmé
vous pourriez devenu ministre c'est
absolument pas mon sujet je dis ça a été
même connu on me l'a proposé je les
refuse et puis pas l'habitude de brader
mes convictions pour emmanuel macron
vous la proposer absolument merci
beaucoup johanna rolland merci maire de
nantes présidente de la métropole de
nantes d'avoir été l'invité de face aux
territoires sur tv5monde diffusion
rediffusion de cette émission sur les
sites internet de nos partenaires co
producteur ouest france.fr nicematin.com
et franceantilles.fr se retrouvent jeudi
prochain à 9h30 en direct sur tv5monde
merci de m merci merci merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]